لقد سمعنا من الناس في جميع أنحاء
الساحل الشرقي الذين سمعوا هذا الذي
كان على ما يبدو من طائرات f-16 التي تم
إرسالها للتزاحم بهذه
الطائرة الخاصة من طراز Cessna Citation وفقًا لمصدر
مطلع على حادثة NORAD
وكلاهما يخبرنا أن هذه الطائرة لم تكن
مستجيبة  على متن الطيار لم
يستجيب لأن هذه الرحلة كانت متجهة من
إليزابيثتون نورث أه آسف في تينيسي
ثم إلى مطار ماك آرثر في لونغ
آيلاند ولكن الطائرة استدارت بعد ذلك
وتجاوزت وجهتها الأصلية
بحوالي 300 ميل أي عندما
سارعت نوراد بطائرات إف -16 في  السعي وراء هذه الطائرة
ويخبرنا NORAD أن هذه الطائرات
النفاثة المقاتلة في Pursuit تم
تخليصها من سرعة الصوت لفترة وجيزة عبر
حاجز الصوت
الذي يؤدي في النهاية إلى انفجار صوتي
وهذا ما تم التقاطه من كاميرات جرس الباب بعيدًا
وواسعًا.
كلب خائف هناك على سطح
منازل أه هناك في شمال فيرجينيا ،
كان هذا على ما يبدو بسبب
عدم استجابة طاقم الطائرة تمامًا وهذا المسار بعد أن
ابتعدت الطائرة عن لونغ آيلاند ،
وذهبت مباشرة فوق العاصمة مباشرة فوق
مقاطعة كولومبيا وهذا هو
مشكلة نظرًا لوجود طبقة من طبقة من
المجال الجوي المقيد ،
لا يُسمح للطائرات غير المستجيبة عادةً
من خلال التحدث إلى
مراقبة الحركة الجوية وإصدار
رمز مستجيب سري إذا لم يكن
لديهم تلك الأشياء وهذا ما يرفع
أجراس الإنذار في  مركز قيادة القوات المسلحة
الأنغولية في وارينتون فيرجينيا ، ولهذا السبب
تم إرسال هذه الطائرات المقاتلة في Pursuit NORAD ،
يقول أيضًا أن هذه الطائرات المقاتلة جاءت
إلى هذه الطائرة بمقاعد Cessna Citation النفاثة
بين حوالي سبعة و 11 شخصًا
وأطلقت مشاعل لمحاولة جذب
انتباه  الطاقم ولكن الطيار كان
فاقدًا للوعي على ما يبدو عند أجهزة التحكم
وتحطمت الطائرة في منطقة ريفية
ليست بعيدة جدًا عن ستانتون فيرجينيا بالقرب من
شارلوتسفيل وهذا ما أدى في
النهاية إلى هذا الحادث.